I went back to Africa this time
exploration had taken on a different
different modality here we were going to
explore the upper headwaters of the
Okavango the quita liver catchment that
flows out of the Angolan highlands Steve
boys and other ng Explorer took us to
the Angolan Highlands after basically 30
years of civil war 15 years of peace at
this point to study this unexplored
River catchment one of the reasons it's
still unexplored is because after Wars
there are there are remnants and
landmines are one of those so what
happens here is that these areas are
kept off-limits by the land mines is a
very tragic catch-22 and as soon as the
land mines are cleared people move in
immediately right and the first thing
they do is they cut down all the trees
and when they cut down all the trees
they use that for charcoal then they
plant cassava which lasts about three
years maybe and then you've got it
basically a dead plot of land so you're
left between well do we do we leave the
landmines in of course you can't do that
but as soon as you do it you look at
massive deforestation and that's
happening all the time there's no
clear-cut answer this is the headwaters
we were doing what's called a source to
sand because the Delta where the water
of the Delta actually doesn't flow to an
ocean it's very unusual every year the
Delta itself in Botswana floods with
1111 cubic kilometers of water it's the
beating heart of southern Africa when it
floods all the migrations come in when
it dries up disperse and it's very
important for southern Africa so this is
the source the idea was to put our
mokoros or dugout canoes on that river
flowing out of the bottom and float the
entire length nam there was not enough
water to float and that is it was good
for me at the time I was I was feeling
so much anger and pain and confusion I
just get in the water with crocodiles
and just start chopping it's tough you
know people like quarry don't chop at
that you're going upstream I'm like oh
okay
turn around
anyway you know we had this opportunity
to finally put the mokoros in the water
and float them and this is what it
looked like in those upper regions you
can see the macaw rose down on the
bottom of the frame this crystal water
but it was slow going on the right side
here as a burn section on the left is a
healthy section the right side is where
people have come in and burned it down
to flush game and hopefully regenerate
unfortunately all that does is it
destroys the root structure and when it
rains it pushes more sand into the river
destroying the flow we were also looking
at these huge blockages it was drudgery
I was cutting through these things we I
mean we're in the water with crocodiles
or you know snakes blisters heatstroke
all of the things that make exploration
really not fun at all and this is days
upon days and why do you do this that's
what that becomes the question and the
answer is that were just I mean you have
to do it we have to understand these
landscapes because so many people and
animals and plants are connected to them
we're all connected right we have to
care for each other so exploration
becomes about showing why it's important
what we found six new to science species
of fishes dozens of new flora reptiles
we were creating a holistic story of the
river catchment and we found the most
biodiverse unexplored corridor on earth
these were the first people that didn't
run from us which makes sense why would
you not run from 12 white dudes on the
chorus not not not a good sight to see
but these people were concerned they
were concerned that the government
didn't know they were there and quite
quite rightly so the government didn't
know they were there the government
hadn't been there in 40 years the last
time with soldiers passing through and
what I started to realize was that their
concerns in the bush were no different
that the concerns of the people in the
Wanda the capital city this is a very
oily and there is enough money to create
a collective sort of well-being in this
country but everybody's concerned about
their own well-being because the country
itself is
concerned about resources so as the oil
prices you know if the oil crunch
happens water becomes sort of a focus
because it can be used for all sorts of
things hydroelectricity
resource or mineral extraction there's
all sorts of things that this water can
be used for and everybody's concerns are
the same you know what happens to our
water this was really a story about
water not about just one River not just
about the Delta at least not for me you
know this is a story about what happens
to the artisanal fishers of Fisheries
after you know overfishing with
industrial fishing what happens to
subsys subsistence fishing what happens
when governments think first of
resources and how does that affect us
downstream and it's not just us it's not
just humans I mean we know that it's big
catch we have a big cat initiative it's
the water that feeds the big cats
it's the aquatic life it's everything
from the Crocs to the fishes to the
algae to the grass right goes all the
way down to the megafauna the elephants
the hippos the rhinos the Buffalo all of
it all the way down to the absolute
tiniest the termites all of this is this
interconnected web and the story doesn't
stop and start with one system it
expands beyond it and where do we fit in
in there how does the human element come
to play because these people the sand
people don't exist anymore this is for
tourism they dress up you know show
tourists what it used to be like in fact
Chris John's who's sitting right here
did one of the last stories when this
was actually genuine and so it stopped
since then so what's happened you know I
the only thing I could think of was a
Norman MacLean quote and it's very
simple eventually all things merge into
one and river runs through it and I
think that's very poignant when I move
forward here this is the last sad
picture of my wife I'm going to show you
but I want to just talk briefly about it
it was funny in all of my assignments
it's only when I totally give myself up
to it
when I totally give myself over to it
when I surrender do I actually start to
see and it was the same with my marriage
only when I totally surrendered
only when she totally surrender did we
actually see each other for who we were
but by that time it was too late
we burned things down and hopefully they
regrow it was serendipitous that this
last spring my sponsor Eddie Bauer asked
if I would like to return to the
mountains the place where this fracture
started the place where the Avalanche
had taken my life and done that with it
and I said of course I'd love to go back
to the mountains where are we going
Everest okay that sounds like a plan I'm
excited to go back and try to reconcile
all of this although I wasn't really
thinking that at the time but I knew I
had to go back I knew I had to go back
to the mountains and I know trust me I
know
it's self-indulgent for you know me a
white American male to go back to
Everest to try to figure my doubt like
come on but stick with me don't walk out
yet I went back with a guy named Adrian
Ballinger and the goal was to try to
climb Everest without oxygen I didn't go
as a photographer we were using as Alice
mentioned a snapchat we were doing
something called Everest no filter and
we were bringing people along up Everest
as we climbed it and we had classrooms
checking in with us talking about you
know physiology and altitude and
geography it was a very very cool
experience to watch it sort of grow
organically we just wanted to take
people along and show what what it was
like to actually be on a real expedition
so I took very few photos this is one
that I actually one of the ones that I
really loved and there aren't that many
in fact I'm only going to show you four
this is the last one this is it twenty
eight thousand nine hundred and fifty
feet so just about
hundred feet vertical feet below Everest
summit on May 24th 2016 and Adrienne had
turned around much earlier in the
morning and I was alone I just passed
these guys that's right I passed people
without oxygen that's cool sounds I'm
not arrogant what I just passed them and
and I turned around and I and I looked
back and I knew I was going to be on the
summit alone which is very rare
vanishingly rare for Everest these days
I I knew I was going to be up there by
myself and when I got there I cried for
a second because I'm a crier and I stood
up as tall as I could and I just reached
up into space because that's as close as
I'm ever going to get I'm not going to
go back and be an astronaut and at the
time I thought you know maybe this is
the punctuation maybe this is the end
maybe this is the end of the darkness
I've climbed my way out I was the
Phoenix Rising I have now proven that I
can overcome anything and and that is
you know I'm I'm good done you know like
put a stamp on it send it away and what
actually happened and I didn't know it
at the time was that was the point where
my biggest lesson was to come that I can
run from everything and I'm good at it
and we all are
I can run as hard and as far and as fast
from the things my demons that bother me
that eat me inside I can go to the top
of the world and they're right there
with me and that is a collective human
experience we cannot run from our issues
ever the point is to turn into them and
face them that's what we have to do you
can go there and they're still right
there with you
so you know my life has never been
normal
I started in these mountains and that's
what brought me up I'm not a
particularly talented human but I'm
willing to try and keep going
it's hard work it's not about I take out
a camera and I
a perfect picture it doesn't work that
way Chris knows that better than anybody
it is one of the hardest things that you
can do I started with the mountains and
the mountains brought me to adventure
and adventure and exploration started to
change the way I saw the world I didn't
care as much about this as I cared about
this what's happening to the planet so
this exploration gave me a different
lens through which to view it you know
and what I've learned from this is that
we're looking for solutions humans are
looking for solutions we want answers to
everything
how do we stop this how do we stop that
what do we do what are the solutions
solutions for climate change you know
and and know that those solutions are
different than the solutions for the
global corrosion of culture they're very
very different how do we solve that and
those solutions are different than the
ones we need for conflicts how do we
deal with that and of course those
solutions are very different than those
that we need to help those who are
affected by conflict former child
soldiers areas like Aleppo how do we
deal with that what are the solutions
there's a lot of questions facing our
world right now
and there aren't any real clear answers
one thing that I believe is that we are
all tied together and by all tied
together I'm not talking about a hippy
oneness of the world I'm talking about
physically everything relies on
everything else it really does in our
day-to-day lives and we need to pay more
attention to that and how do we honor
that bond because we will find solutions
we are very very good at finding
solutions X what humans do we have very
big brains and we put band-aids on
things you know as a generalist my goal
with my photography is not to focus on
one thing I don't want to be great at
one thing I want to tell multiple
stories
different voices and lenses I want to
step back I want to ask the question not
how do we solve the problems we have how
do we stop creating the problems right
what's the answer to that why do I get
up here and talk about divorce and PTSD
and infidelity and adventure and and you
know and and I confuse the whole topic I
mean I've talked about alcoholism I've
talked about sustainability you guys are
like what is the through-line I mean I
get it dude but what is the through-line
where are you going with this the
through line is this we are the stewards
and every single choice we make has a
consequence every single one and that is
very important to remember I'm 35 years
old I don't have the answers I can tell
you to ride bikes I can tell you to eat
less meat I can tell you to take shorter
showers I can tell you to not use
plastic bags don't use straws you know
buy a Prius whatever you can do you guys
know that we do need initiatives like
pristine seas we do need initiatives
like big cats we do need to focus that
but those honestly are band-aids on
existing wounds so what is the virus and
how do we how do we address that and
honestly honestly I think the answer is
much much simpler than we're making it
but I'm not audacious enough to say that
so I'm going to let somebody else say it
in different words he's he's a little
smarter than me not much you might have
heard of him his name is Carl Sagan
we're about you you know anyway that
little dot there if you haven't seen
this before this photograph is called
the pale blue dot and that dot and that
Sunbeam is us that's earth that was
taken from 3.7 billion miles away in
February 14 1990 and this is what Carl
my buddy Carl had say
this look again at that dot that's here
that's home that's us on it everyone you
love everyone you know everyone you've
ever heard of every human being who ever
was lived out their lives the aggregate
of our joy and suffering thousands of
confident religions ideologies and
economic doctrines every hunter and
forager every hero and coward every
creator and destroyer of civilization
every King and peasant every young
couple in love every mother and father
hopeful child inventor and Explorer
every teacher of morals every corrupt
politician every superstar every Supreme
Leader every saint and sinner in the
history of our species lived there on a
mote of dust suspended in a sunbeam the
earth is a very small stage in a vast
cosmic arena think of the endless
cruelties visited by the inhabitants of
one corner of this pixel on the scarcely
distinguishable inhabitants of some
other corner how frequent their
misunderstandings how eager they are to
kill one another how fervent their
hatreds think of the rivers of blood
spilled by all those generals and
emperors so that in glory and triumph
they could become the momentary masters
of a fraction of a dot our posturings
our imagined self-importance the
delusion that we have some privileged
position in the universe are challenged
by this point of pale light our planet
is a lonely speck in the great
enveloping cosmic dark in our obscurity
in all this vastness there is no hint
that help will come from elsewhere to
save us from ourselves the earth is the
only world known so far to harbor life
there is nowhere else at least in the
near future to which our species could
migrate
visit yes settle not yet like it or not
for the moment the earth is where we
make our stand it has been said that
astronomy is a humbling and
character-building experience there is
perhaps no better demonstration of the
folly of human conceits than this
distant image of our tiny world to me it
underscores our responsibility to deal
more kindly with one another
and to preserve and cherish the pale
blue dot the only home we've ever known
now think about that for a second
Carl Sagan was pretty smart but he
didn't end with policy he didn't end
with carbon emissions he didn't end with
rainforests he didn't end with any of
that because those are the wounds that's
what's happened he ended with kindness
it's the most simple thing because when
we act kindly towards one another in
this city especially right now we act
kindly towards one another we hear each
other we treat each other with respect
we might not agree and when there are
abuses we stand up for that but we treat
each other with kindness and respect and
the root of that dare I say it as a 35
year old man who's done all sorts of
horrible things the root of that is the
one thing that makes us different as an
animal it's the single most important
thing we do it's unique to us and that
is love that's what we do and that in
and of itself is where we start so
without saying too much more I love you
guys very much and thank you for sharing
this with me
[Applause]
[Music]